this week on sternthology we're going to
be celebrating mun madness we're calling
it mund madness uh as you know ronnie
the smallest thing can make you explode
one of our angry ronnie experts is mike
perlman producer mike perlman has some
rules on how to avoid making ronnie
angry so i put together you know a few
rules to abide by uh because you don't
want ronnie flying off the handle
anymore you know you're over 70 years
old i don't want anything happening to
you that's the thing so
no i'll start with a couple rules rule
number one never call ronnie ugly
i don't know if you remember the ugly
meter incident 10 years ago this month a
young guy software developer came into
the studio he was promoting this app and
what the app did was it measured how
ugly you are ronnie scored a zero he
took it to heart and he went right off
on the guy never call ronnie you're
supposed to be here promoting your app
no i'm not i'm here to see you get on my
[ __ ] camera call me [ __ ] ugly
honey because i will throw your ass out
of here
first of all
i got a 34. that's nothing to be proud
of yeah okay and he takes pictures of
sal's [ __ ] and balls and he gets a two
give me a [ __ ] break
he got really mad that day right mike
yeah i remember he ran into the studio
he got in the guy's face the guy was
sitting on the couch and he you know you
know ronnie's the guy that's doing
security i mean
i guess that's what the you know the
serious security guys were up there for
they were there to do the real security
because ronnie was just you know he's so
easy to fly off the handle as i said
well you're so funny you're such a funny
i mean
you're the guy that's supposed to keep
everybody calm you're running you're
such a funny dude what's rule number two
okay rule number two is never question
ronnie's body image you know he's very
sensitive about his looks
back in 2018 we realized that the press
photo he's been using had his face
photoshopped onto the body of dean kane
wait a minute the guy who played
superman stop right there that was not
my press photo
it was a press photo i remember it no it
wasn't
it was in the newspaper or something for
appearances i go ronnie that's not your
body he goes what are you talking about
he started fighting with me i remember
right you got the same exact red mark on
your chest as dean kane
i didn't have no clue it was [ __ ]
dean kane your head you know i was just
thinking of something i'm going to stop
breaking my balls because i had no clue
about it how do you not know your own
body
i i didn't study it that closely that
it's dean i'm very close full of crap
come on your neck is twice the size
that's my face i don't have to that's
all i looked at ron you didn't know you
weren't that jacked dude i wasn't
looking at it that closely i was looking
at my face and that was me dude he loved
me
i wasn't seeing it wasn't a picture of
me and without a shirt on
me without a shirt i wouldn't you had to
you had a magnificent body in that
picture i mean your arms were rippling
everybody else who looked at it knew it
wasn't your body because they [ __ ]
studied it i didn't nobody studied it
was really obvious yeah okay robin rule
number three don't question ronnie's
choice of breakfast series for the last
year ronnie's been at war with his
caller apples ronnie's fiance stephanie
posted a picture to instagram that had
the serial lucky charms attached to it
uh and apple's called to ask ronnie if
he eats these sugary cereals and ronnie
you know immediately he lost it apples
hey kind of [ __ ] here use your real
[ __ ] name apples what the [ __ ] kind
of name is that apples
who cares if stephanie eats uh lucky
charms that's why
don't you get it that's why he called
stephanie puts this [ __ ] up on [ __ ]
instagram i knew somebody was gonna
[ __ ] do it i said some [ __ ] is gonna
call into this [ __ ] show and ask
probably apples oh does stephanie eat
[ __ ] lucky charms why would he
[ __ ] call why would he [ __ ] call
ronnie exactly you realize now how silly
you sound i mean you're not carrying not
at all i think you think that's normal
who cares let him go [ __ ] himself you
get too amped up you really gotta walk
on eggshells with him uh rule number
four
never put ronnie in charge of food you
know it always comes back to food you
know um there were cookies delivered to
our office
jason called ronnie out for divvying up
the cookies onto the plates before
anyone could get to the table right over
the top yesterday over [ __ ] black and
white cookies
stupid [ __ ]
i'm trying to be a nice [ __ ] guy and
[ __ ] jason could shove him up his ass
he can have them all okay how come you
are all right how come we forget about
it how come when a guy take whatever you
want from me how come
don't even [ __ ] look at me you
don't even [ __ ] listen
why did you divvy up the cookies ron
there was so much [ __ ] there so many
cupcakes that there was no reason to let
them get thrown away at the end of the
day so sometimes i would bring them out
to the people outside so they can enjoy
them what's the big [ __ ] deal ronnie
was like the mayor of the cookies why
did that bother you so much i don't
understand ronnie would take it upon
himself to put these plates together and
he'd walk around serious oh here's one
for the the receptionist uh he has a
special delivery to the 37th floor
here's the special guest dude mike when
ronnie was
taking these cupcakes and delivering
them was it mostly to hot girls it was
only they would always be like a cute
girl out [ __ ] you know out in the
lobby don't [ __ ] lie he'd bring him
out there you know
i'll bring him out there yeah i'm trying
to be cool yeah i'll talk like uh yeah
i'm i'm the [ __ ] i'm the i'm the
tough guy yeah
yeah yes bring them out there and to get
back about that to get back to ronnie's
anger like you know as we as i was
saying like i've never heard a guy get
so angry about this nonsense if cookie's
gonna set you off like that there's
gotta be something like if cookies are
gonna set you up like that i mean you
gotta explode
i'm just imitating a [ __ ] over here
let's try to make something out of
nothing honey i didn't know you did
impressions you're fabulous yes i do
stop showing off
mike pearlman yeah i'm the man yeah you
want to see my scar yeah look at my scar
man i got shot look at me this is the
[ __ ] the oscars cuts away from it's
amazing to me that ronnie is still angry
about all these things that happened
years ago all right what is the fifth
rule rule number five never mess with
ronnie's food yes mike take your own
advice all right in 2019 ronnie claimed
that he set aside a bagel to eat later
during one of our bagel wednesdays right
he insisted that he had wrapped it in a
paper towel i know he left the green
room he came back to find it wrapped
differently than he remembered he was
convinced that i did something to his
bagel here we go somebody unwrapped my
[ __ ] bagel you know what it is it's
you i know it's you by the way you did
it with the bagel
what is the bagel sitting on there was
one little napkin sitting on top ronnie
nobody's no dude if somebody [ __ ] with
your food you'd be out of your [ __ ]
mind oh i'd be little [ __ ] with my head
and i will be irrational is a joke if
someone messes with your bagel this is
the [ __ ] joke the [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass up this is a [ __ ]
joke all week on howard 101 sternthology
will be celebrating monday you stay the
[ __ ] away from me yeah i'm not yelling
i'm always yelling let's hear it this is
my man go [ __ ] yourselves so damn man
shut up and let me talk yeah
go away
[Music]